>> Laura: THE SMOLLETT HOAXES
ONE OF MANY THAT FIT A PATTERN,
ANGRY PEOPLE UNLEASHING VICIOUS
AND HATE FILLED ATTACKS AGAINST
OR RACIAL MINORITIES.
HERE ARE A FEW OF MORE THAN
DOZENS THAT ARE OUT THERE.
IN DECEMBER 2015 A MUSLIM WOMAN
SAID SHE WAS ATTACKED BY THREE
WHITE TRUMP SUPPORTERS IN
NEW YORK CITY ON SUBWAY.
SHE SAID THEY TRY TO RIP OFF HER
HIJAB.
WELL, IT NEVER HAPPENED.
THEN ONE DAY AFTER THE 2016
ELECTION, STUDENT AT
BOWLING GREEN AND OHIO SAID THAT
WHITE MALES WEARING TRUMP SHIRTS
THREW ROCKS AT HER AND HURLED
RACIAL SLURS.
PROTESTS AT A UNIVERSITY
TOWN HALL ENSUED.
THE STUDENT MADE UP THE ENTIRE
INCIDENT.
AND IN SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR,
HOME AND TOLD LONG ISLAND SHE
WAS DRIVING HOME WHEN FOUR TEENS
CONFRONTED HER AND YELLED TRUMP
2016 AND THEN THEY TOLD HER "SHE
DIDN'T BELONG HERE."
THAT TOO WAS MADE UP.
HERE NOW WITH IS DINESH D'SOUZA,
CONSERVATIVE FILMMAKER AND
AUTHOR.
WHAT DOES THIS TELL US ABOUT THE
CURRENT LOCAL CLIMATE AND THE
CULTURE TODAY?
>> WELL THE FIRST THING IT TELLS
US IS THAT THESE FAKE RACIAL
INCIDENTS HAVE BECOME NORMALIZE
NORMALIZED.
WHEN THE CASE BROKE A GENERATION
AGO, THIS WAS A BOGUS RACIAL
INCIDENT INVOLVING AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN WOMAN WHO HAD
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN ABUSED ANDB
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN ABUSED ANDT
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN ABUSED ANDE
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN ABUSED AND,
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN ABUSED ANDI
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN ABUSED ANDT
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN ABUSED ANDW
CLAIMED TO HAVE BEEN ABUSED ANDS
ANOMALOUS.
PEOPLE REALLY HAD TO SCRATCH
THEIR HEADS BECAUSE THIS IS SUCH
A FREAK EPISODE.
BUT NOW THERE IS A PROFESSION OF
THESE BOGUS INCIDENTS OF WHICH
THE JUSSIE SMOLLETT CASES ONLY
THE LATEST.
I THINK FOR PEOPLE WATCHING,
THEY ARE A LITTLE BAFFLED
BECAUSE I PROBABLY THINK WHAT
KIND OF DEMENTIA CAUSES SOMEONE
TO DO THIS?
WHY WOULD SOMEDAY FABRICATE AN
INCIDENT?
AND I THINK WE ARE DEALING HERE
NOT SO MUCH WITH PERSONAL
DEMENTIA BUT WHAT CAN BE CALLED
IDEOLOGICAL DEMENTIA.
YOU TOUCHED ON IT EARLIER.
THERE IS AN NARRATIVE HERE THAT
THEY ARE TRYING TO ADVANCE.
THE NARRATIVE IS THAT THE MAGA
SUPPORTERS, THE TRUMP PEOPLE,
ARE A BUNCH OF RACES.
IT'S OBVIOUSLY A TRIBUTE TO THE
TRUMP-STRS THAT THEY ARE NOT
RACIST BECAUSE JUSSIE SMOLLETT
DESPITE BEING BLACK AND
FLAMBOYANTLY GAY ARE GOING
OUT THERE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE TO
PICK ON THEM AND NOBODY IS.
SO THE FACTS ARE NOT SUPPORTING
THE NARRATIVE AT ALL.
SO THEY FIGURE WHY NOT MAKE UP
THE FACTS?
WHY NOT ADAPT THE FACTS OF THE
NARRATIVE RATHER THAN THE OTHER
WAY AROUND, AND I THINK THIS IS
THE DEMENTED PSYCHOLOGY, THE
DEMENTED PROGRESSIVE PSYCHOLOGY
THAT DRIVES THESE RACIAL FAKED
INCIDENTS.
THE SECOND REASON FOR THEM IS
THAT THEY GET AWAY WITH IT.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT MY
POINT, DINESH, CONSERVATIVES ARE
QUICK TO SAY LET'S MOVE ON.
I DON'T WANT TO DWELL ON THIS.
THE FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
PEOPLE IN JAIL AFTER WHAT
HAPPENED TO BRETT KAVANAUGH,
WITH THAT JULIE SWETNICK, WHAT
MICHAEL AVENATTI WAS PUSHING,
ALL THE PROMISES OF EVIDENCE OF
HOW HE
WAS DRUGGING PEOPLE, SPIKING THE
PUNCH BOWL, GAIN RAPE.
PEOPLE WANT TO MOVE ON FROM
THAT?
I SAY NO WAY.
OTHERWISE THAT STUFF CONTINUES.
SAME DEAL WITH THE SMOLLETT
CASE.
IT OCCUPIED EVERYBODY'S TIME,
AND THE CHICAGO PD WAS DEMONIZED
AND OF COURSE TRUMP SUPPORTERS
ARE MADE OUT TO BE THESE
HORRIBLE, AWFUL, TERRIBLE, WRONG
PEOPLE BECAUSE LOOK, YOUR PEOPLE
ARE DOING THIS TO THIS POOR
ACTOR.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT TO REALIZE
THAT THE JUSSIE SMOLLETT
INCIDENT IS A HATE CRIME.
IT'S A HATE CRIME BUT IN THE
OPPOSITE DIRECTION.
REMEMBER JUSSIE SMOLLETT
BASICALLY WANTED TO GO AND BEAT
HIMSELF UP, THAT'S NOT AGAINST
THE LAW.
THE REAL CRIME HERE WAS
ATTEMPTING TO PIN THIS PLANE ON
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO DID
NOTHING, ON INNOCENT PEOPLE.
IT IS THIS IDEA OF TRYING TO
ULTIMATELY FRAME TRUMP
SUPPORTERS FOR SOMETHING THAT
SMOLLETT HIMSELF PERPETRATED, SO
HE'S THE PERPETRATOR
MASQUERADING AS A VICTIM.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT HE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
OTHERWISE THE LEFT THINKS LET'S
KEEP TRYING THIS.